is there water on the moon the obvious
answer seems to be no because during a
day on the moon which lasts to earth
weeks the temperature on the lunar
surface gets up 223 degrees celsius
which would be enough to boil away any
water if the moon had an atmosphere like
Earth which it doesn't and the reason
that it doesn't is because the moon's
gravity is weak just a sixth of Earth's
gravity which means it can't hold on to
light fast-moving molecules like water
anything going faster than 2.4
kilometers per second
the moon's escape velocity is gone then
that might sound pretty quick but at any
given temperature there are always a
small number of molecules going
significantly faster than the average on
the moon these molecules fly off into
space and then other molecules take
their place until all the light
fast-moving molecules are gone
Plus since the moon has a very weak
magnetic field there's little to protect
the lunar surface from the solar wind
that's the stream of charged particles
coming from the Sun these particles can
effectively blast molecules from the
surface of the moon into space in fact
that's how Mars lost most of its
atmosphere so in short if the moon ever
had any water it should be long gone by
now
and this appeared to be confirmed by the
moon landings rock samples brought back
by Apollo astronauts contained virtually
no hydrated minerals some water was
detected but it was assumed just to be
terrestrial contamination rather than
actual moon water because seals on some
of the sample return containers were
damaged by the gritty moon dust but in
2009 a very different picture emerged
when scientists intentionally crashed
part of a rocket into the surface of the
moon it was going to point five
kilometres per second on impact making a
crater 25 metres wide and 4 metres deep
that objective 10,000 tons of material
with half of it making it high enough to
be lit by the Sun that allowed cameras
on an orbiting spacecraft to look for
the emission lines of water in the dust
and what did they find
well the water emission lines were
bright scientists estimated that 5.6
percent the mass of the ejected debris
was water
but how is this possible where does the
water come from and how did it remain on
the moon well strangely enough there are
actually three different sources of
lunar water to understand the first
source you just have to look at where
they crashed that rocket into the moon
now it's a misconception that the moon
has a dark side although the same side
always faces earth all sides of the moon
do receive sunlight however at the poles
there are some craters which due to
their location and death are always in
shade they're called the permanently
shadowed regions now since they never
see the Sun these craters are some of
the coldest places in the whole solar
system colder than the surface of Pluto
they can reach negative 249 Celsius and
it is here that scientists decided to
crash that piece of rocket since the
permanently shadowed regions maintain
such a consistently low temperature they
act as cold trapped places where
volatiles like water remain frozen as
ice but where would the water come from
in the first place
well from water containing comets and
asteroids that have struck the moon over
time any water molecules that found
their way to the permanently shadowed
regions would be trapped there forever
as ice but this is not the only source
of water on the moon in the lunar
samples from Apollo 15 and 17 scientists
found tiny glass beads these beads
reforms back when the moon was still
volcanically active fire fountains
launched droplets of lava into space
where they cooled rapidly and then fell
back to the surface in 2007 these beads
were sliced in half and tested for water
the results showed significant amounts
of water with concentrations highest in
the middle of the beads now this
indicates that the water must have been
trapped there during the initial
eruption rather than leaching in due to
contamination once those beads were back
on earth now this water came from the
interior of the moon so the moon must
have contained water to begin with which
kind of makes sense considering the moon
is likely a piece of Earth that broke
off billions of years ago in impact with
a mars-sized body the third and final
source of water on the moon is
water created on the moon's surface from
the reaction of oxygen and hydrogen now
the source of oxygen is easy oxygen
makes up 35% of the lunar surface
mostly bound in oxide mineral but where
do you get the free hydrogen the answer
is in the solar wind which is constantly
bombarding the moon's surface with
protons these can react with oxygen to
form hydroxides and ultimately water
this water can then drift over the
surface of the Moon until either it
flies off into space or it lands in the
cold traps and becomes ice so there is
water on the moon and this is important
because it means that future missions
can take advantage of this valuable
resource not only for moon colonists to
drink and grow crops but also for
processing into rocket fuel if you can
make your own rocket fuel on the moon
that dramatically reduces the challenges
and costs of space travel for a long
time we used to think the moon was
completely dry but now we know that
hypothesis is all wet why big news I
have a brand new channel called science
iam where I'm posting videos in this
format so if you enjoyed this video you
should go check out that channel and
subscribe to it the more of you who do
the more videos I will make over there
now making this new channel was made
possible by Google's making and science
initiative a team that seeks to inspire
people to learn more about science and
pursue their science goals and of course
none of this would be possible without
your support on patreon so I want to
thank you for supporting me and I want
to thank Google for making it possible
for me to pursue my science goals and
make a new channel all about awesome
discoveries in science so if you click
on this link I will see you over on the
new channel